تشدد الاشتباكات بمحيط مجمع اليرموك في
الخرطومه مياه سد نوفا كخوفكا تغرق 14 الف
منزل في خرسون صوره لالون ماسك طفلا تغزو
السوشيال ميديا هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد الحريق الضخم الذي استعر في احد
صهاريج تخزين النفط بمنشاه الشجره القريبه
من مجمع اليرموك بالخرطوم تجددت
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في محيط هذا المجمع شهود عيان
اكدوا ان اشتباكات تدور في مجمع محيط مجمع
الصناعه العسكريه هذا في جنوب الخرطوم وسط
التصاعد لدخان كما افادوا بان اصوات اطلاق
نار سمعت في المنطقه المحيطه باليرموك
التي تعد ابرز منشات التصنيع العسكري في
البلاد وفقا لما نقلته وكالات فرانسبريس
[موسيقى]
هي كارثه بكل ما للكلمه من معنى تعيشها
منطقه خرسون في الجنوب الاوكراني حيث غرقت
الاف المنازل انهيار سادكه خوفتا بحسب ما
اكد الكسندر بروكودينا حاكم منطقه
في تعليق على انستغرام ان المياه تغمر نحو
600 كيلومتر مربع من المنطقه مضيفا ان
متوسط منسوب المياه بلغ نحو سته امتار
فيما اعلنت هيئه الطوارئ بمقاطعه خيرسون
ان المياه غمرت نحو 14 الف منزل في 15
بلده بالمقاطعه
تداعيات تفجير سد كخوفكا لن يقتصر على
اوكرانيا فقد بل سيمتد اثره للعالم ايضا
اذ حذر برنامج الغذاء العالمي التابع
للامم المتحده من حدوث تداعيات مدمره
بالنسبه للاشخاص الذين يعانون الجوع على
مستوى العالم اجمع نتيجه
الامم المتحده اوضحت ان الفيضانات ستقضي
على الحبوب المزروعه حديثا وبالتالي ستقضي
على امال 345 مليون شخص يعانون الجوع في
انحاء العالم مشيره الى ان الحبوب القادمه
من اوكرانيا تعد بمثابه انقاذ لحياتهم
قصه اثار الضجه واسعه بطلها مليونير صينيه
يبلغ من العمر 56 عاما يصر على نيل شهاده
الثانويه العامه بعد محاولات عده فاشله
تقارير افادت بان المليونير الذي يدعى
تقدم الامتحانات جو كاو المساويه للثانويه
العامه للمره 27 بعد اخفاقه بنيل علامه
كافيه في امتحان القبول في مؤسسات التعليم
العالي ليتمكن من الالتحاق بالجامعه وحسب
ما قالوا ليانك انه كان حزينا لانه لم
يتمكن من استكمال تعليم للجامعي لكنه اكد
الاستمرار في تقديمها حتى النجاح
في خبرنا الاخير اجتاحت خلال الساعات
الماضيه صوره غريبه لمالك العصفور الازرق
ايلون ماسك وهو طفل صغير يرتدي قميصا ابيض
وازرارا بنيت اللون وقست شعر لكن الصوره
لم تكن طبيعيه ولم تلتقت له وهو صغير بل
كانت بفعل الذكاء الاصطناعي مغرضون عله
على الصوره بان ماسك كان يعمل على بعض
التركيبات المضاده للشيخوخه لكنها خرجت عن
بطاقه السيطره يرد مصر قائلا يبدو انني
اخذت جرعات مبالغ فيها